What's up, guys?
I'm gonna talk about some jobs you didn't know
that the hospital offers.
That you don't need any education.
So first things first,
there's transport.
You take patient from A to B,
see every student department.
Two, PCA. Same thing as a CNA.
But you don't need to spend 13 dollars.
Thirteen hundred dollars on a certificate.
No more used.
Apply. Three.
Another one no one thinks about is EVS. Used.
Go around the hospital,
clean up everywhere,
from trauma to surgery
to patient floors to the emergency room.
And you can see what job you might like, you know?
And another one a lot of people sleep on
is volunteer work.
Top in. You start meeting the management.
You start meeting managers
and you start seeing what's what's up in the hospital.
So these are some jobs for you guys to.
To keep in mind.